we do a real live action toy story where
we take a 65 year old tom hanks and a 68
year old tim allen we put them in a
cowboy outfit and a little spaceman suit
and we have them run away from a 65 foot
tall
eight-year-old
so today we're going to talk about
animated
shows and movies that deserve a live
action version we've got this article up
on
looper.com that has a lot of interesting
choices that
no disrespect to the writer i don't love
because a lot of them involve animals
and i feel like the lion king remake
makes me feel like some of them would be
not great but
what do i know you know because they
wouldn't necessarily be live action if
they're all just computer generated
that's not really live action but here
we are i'm just gonna
what were some of the examples there if
you don't mind me asking so i think one
that could work
that could work best out of some of
these is american tail with fievel you
know a little mountain membrane comes
through america you know you can film it
on city streets you can make practical
sets if you wanted to
i'll do it with puppets i have no idea
but if you did cg
i i would i would wonder about how well
that would work
you know yeah we don't want to get too
far into the uncanny valley situation
wishbone style would be interesting so
is it live action or is it cg right
right you know land before time is on
here that's you know disney has a
version of that called dinosaur they
also did a pixar at the good dinosaur
not the same story but same idea
secret of nim
is that live action
all dogs go to heaven is one that could
work that's a pretty good example here
right that is a tough seller really yeah
like i'm saying as far as working in
live action
what you're what you're pitching right
now is a movie where we watched two dogs
die
in real life this time okay yeah cool
i'm gonna go ahead and make the first
act
but we can get charlie sheen involved
again
he was in the sequel right it was it was
uh what's his name what was that what
was the sequel all dogs go to hell
featured
who was in the first one
it was um i don't know i don't know but
i'm very thrown by the beginning of this
entire
bert reynolds was the star of all dogs
go to heaven one uh-huh
now he is in heaven charlie sheen was i
believe the voice of charlie and all
dogs go to heaven too
um where they team up with some other
kid
dom deluise was in it right does it none
of this matters
wasn't the first one actually end with
them sending a dog to hell i only
watched it one time when i was a kid don
bluth
no dude the dog never goes to hell
doesn't the guy dog at the end go to
hell no he goes to heaven he goes to
doggy heaven he's really upset about it
because he doesn't want to be dead and
he hates heaven because it's so nice but
all the dogs go to the same it is
my earlier statement all right it's time
to yeah no we got to explore this
universe there's some
deeply fascinating theology stuff here
yeah
we've got watership down on here as well
which is one i don't think i can get
behind for various reasons so we'll move
right past it
no fern gully could work
oh that was they did that it was avatar
next
okay moving on
moving on
i'm scrolling i'm scrolling i'm looking
for any that don't start animals here we
go this is one of the ones that i wanted
to talk about
so if we decided to cut everything we
just talked about i would say an
animated movie or show that i think
could get a live-action reboot that
would be really great would be gargoyles
are either of you familiar with
gargoyles i love gargoyles
can you tell me about it
gargoyles
is the story of
these gargoyles
that's about as succinct as it gets that
was really well right i understand
everything now we can all go
like vampires they can't operate during
the day when the sun goes down right i
mean they break out of the ground
their stone forms and become
monstrous superheroes so the strongholds
are like shells they just like bust out
and they're like exactly okay exactly
it's got a great theme song which goes
like
[Music]
blah
it's gonna be great footage to just
layer together you doing that and then
the opening sequence from gargoyles i
want everyone to come to know that we're
all wearing headphones for this show and
that
you're welcome that hurts yeah i made
sure to turn my sound settings way up
because i was having trouble with the
microphone so it's as loud as it gets
um so but so the story of gargoyles is
that is that back in medieval times
middle ages whatever um
humans and gargoyles coexisted gargoyles
protected the kingdom
and
on because of some kind of curse they
were you know they were basically like
cursed to sleep forever you know like in
their stone forms yeah and then
eventually happens to the best of us
the castle is moved from medieval europe
to new york in like modern day by a bad
businessman guy named zion freaks
voiced by commander riker jonathan
frakes yes another star trek reference
or thomas riker come on
or thomas riker his evil transporter
clone
um not evil but you know but anyway so
then the curse is lifted and they become
modern day protectors of new york and
it's great it's this great cartoon it's
on disney plus if you haven't checked it
out you should it's a good show uh keith
david did the voice of
uh goliath the lead the the main guy and
the voice is perfect keith david's an
amazing actor an amazing voice actor
i would love to see a live-action
gargoyles i think it's probably one of
my favorite items on this list as an
idea because disney owns the ip they're
always looking for new stuff to do with
their
intellectual property
it's something that's not marvel it's
not disney uh it's not star wars i mean
it's it's fully disney owned and they
could just do it whenever they're ready
and it would have an already like
rabid fan base that would be totally
into it
i would love to see it i think gargoyles
would be awesome i think that would be
cool would you want it to be like
it would be mostly cg though right
no that's the thing it takes place it
takes place in modern day new york so
you'd have like
like you know like tmnt style like the
michael gray produced right right right
right not cgi characters right but then
humans alongside them got it exactly
cool alvin and the chipmunk style sonic
and style
the hedgehog style sonic the hedgehog
yeah style we take people's faces and we
plug them into
a cat style yeah
yeah
digital fur technology digital for
technology we are living in the golden
age people let's take advantage golden
age of a cinema yeah and the only the
only other one on here that i really
responded to is voltron which is
fascinating right here
there he is there's voltron right there
voltron
i mean basically voltron is power
rangers
that's basically what it is but not
quite
quite so heavy on the it's not quite as
heavy on the goofy kung fu action you
know the martial arts action that that
happens in a lot of power rangers shows
it was animated but you know instead of
zords they're lions they all get into
their lions the lions form a giant robot
the robot fights aliens i could just
just
just like just like in nature that's
that's in the lion king everyone knows
it's funny i think i saw a documentary
about that on animal planet yeah yeah
that's right when simba was finally
ready to ascend he formed up with four
other lions and fought scar who was at
that point a giant row beast
um yeah but i would love to see everyone
knows that story it's a tale as old as
time oh
it was good yes well lions joined
together
this
this is this is getting rougher
it's a musical episode
that's perfect it's a very special
episode of blossom here
at the looper talk show
is this better or worse than the musical
episode of grey's anatomy um
much worse
so yeah so those are my big picks
voltron and gargoyles are my two faves
from my childhood and and even
revisiting the the netflix had a voltron
reboot that was um
animated and excellent really good stuff
um didn't quite
you know uh
get to the finish line unscathed the end
of the series wasn't as good as the rest
of it
you know would make you hope that the
finale was but overall i'd still really
recommend it to anyone who likes perfect
action sci-fi comedy giant robots cool
stuff so the stuff everybody likes yeah
the stuff everyone likes
forever nina yeah yeah
your response to my question that is
this topic
here is my answer that was like the
weighted movies and shows
the worst like yoda jeopardy phrasing
i've never heard um
well this was an easy answer i i believe
it is in the article on looper.com but i
probably would have picked it anyway um
because it's one of my favorite shows
ever um and if we're singing theme songs
i feel like you probably both know it's
wow
uh it's daria i love daria very much i
first started watching it on um the end
a channel that kept me as an unpopular
high schooler company between its
airings of degrassi the next generation
and daria um
yeah but daria i'm sure you're both
familiar with daria is about a
misanthropic teenager who's way smarter
than everybody else and she hangs out
with her cool artist best friend jane
lane and they watch six sad world and
her parents are weird and funny and her
sister's cute and popular and hijinks
and sue um but it is a very very
insightful funny show about like what
it's like to be different in high school
and
and what it's like to kind of be wise
beyond your years and
her kind of struggling with that she
wants to be an outsider but sometimes
she does want to just be a little more
you know kind of mainstream and fit in
and it's a great show it's super funny
her her dad is the most neurotic uh
character in television history
parents are so good uh she also has that
one teacher that's always i don't
remember his name but like one of his
eyeballs is always like in danger of
leaving his head yeah because he's
really mad all the time and then she
also has that like wishy-washy dope of a
teacher who's always like guys why can't
we just hold hands and be friends um
there's
a sister this quinn uh who is a lot
smarter than her dopey friends in the
fashion club but fashion club the
fashion club yeah
her friend sandy with the weird monotone
voice and then tiffany who talks like
this
um
yeah
the cheerleader brittany and her really
dumb boyfriend kevin great cast great
everything
it's a great show and we have someone
like there was there were rumors about
this and they just never happened and i
don't know why but like aubry plaza is
right there just go get her
and have her play daria she is right
there i can't imagine anyone else doing
that
uh she still looks like she could i
would even even if she doesn't look 17
i'd be like i don't care whatever just
don't dear evan hansen her just let her
do it i was just gonna say you you might
have a dear evan hansen situation yeah
because everybody would just be like no
this is correct like this makes complete
sense
everybody would be cool about it and
also we wouldn't nobody would put makeup
on her to make her look like stupid
chemi and 30 rock going how do you do
fellow kids um
like she won't look like an undercover
cop um but
but no i i i mean
and like there's so many i feel like
meredith hagner who was in palm springs
and search party would be really funny
as brittany
oh my god yes you would crush it like i
think it'd be really fun to like fan
cast this um like maybe laurie metcalf
could be her like high strung lawyer mom
i don't know who i want to be heard
neurotic dad yet but i mean i don't i
don't think i need to like
we're all cool with this right this is
just a thing that should have happened a
long time ago a daughter live action but
makes sense there's no
you know fantastical animals you don't
have to have any cgi it could just be a
funny smart show and also they could
make more uh six ad world hypotheticals
and i would really really love that
because i want to watch that show for
real i want to watch daria live on
screen someone call aubry
get our agent on the phone let's go
you know that they'll probably they'll
probably reboot it for netflix in a few
years and it's just going to be the
worst
it'll just be the worst
i
yeah so it could be but i also will say
like this is not a reboot i mean it
actually it's a reboot of movies and a
book series but like netflix region uh
babysitter's club and it's really good
okay so there you go it's actually like
and i'm not alone in this critics
actually like it but it's like an
endearing nice well-written show with
alicia silverstone hanging out as a
parent oh that's awesome um yeah and so
it's like well then what if they just
get on it if they could pull off
babysitter's club maybe they could do
daria let's see what they've got yeah
alicia silverstone plays a parent in it
yeah we're all old
is she being like a regular parent or
like an alicia's she's baby birding
anyone yeah
if that were the case i would not be
singing this show's praises
and shawn from the good place is a dad
but not a demon this time
oh cool luckily yeah
yeah all right anyway daria that's my
pick thomas jackson
thomas i think that's his name tom it is
kevin jackson how are you
what do you got what do you got for us i
hate
tom i i don't like to pick the low
hanging fruit brian
you know that about me but i think
there's one obvious choice it's pretty
good it's a classic the best part about
it is you could get
all the people who played the characters
originally to come back in and play them
in live action
i think we all know what i'm talking
about 1995 it's toy story we do a real
live action toy story where we take a 65
year old tom hanks and a 68 year old tim
allen we put them in a cowboy outfit and
a little space man suit and we have them
run away from a 65 foot tall
eight-year-old
[Music]
he gets tied to a giant firework and
exploded in front of everybody
ooh
where are we getting real
pictured
can we get some uh can we get some
dinosaur bones and do some science magic
and make a dinosaur and make him be in
the movie
the worst thing i've ever heard
how do we make it how do we make a human
piggy bank a human piggy bank sounds
like a joke from a staphon sketch on snl
[Laughter]
what's a human piggy bank guys i came up
with this idea 45 minutes ago and i've
been having a hard time thinking about
it
coins in your shirt and then you let
them fall into the floor and you're like
i'm a piggy bank
thing where a man in the front of the
club opens his mouth and you have to
feed him quarters to get in
there you go
i was gonna say nina thank you for for
keeping it pg more about where you're
putting the coins
if snl can keep stefan pg then we all
can do it
and then you come back later and shake
them out
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe